get ready for a public fam for reunion
we're still together for the rest of our
lives this is true together yeah we
already knew that Megan Markel and
Prince Harry are scheduled to attend the
upcoming Commonwealth Day service at
Westminster Abbey but the palace just
confirmed that Prince William and Kate
Middleton will join them Queen Elizabeth
Prince Charles and Camilla are also
confirmed attendees of the March 9th
event the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge
are scheduled to make an official trip
to Ireland from March 3rd through the
5th but they'll be back just in time for
Commonwealth Day the last thing you
disagreed on how to resolve it a source
previously told et that William and
Harry are talking more and they're on
better footing after a difficult period
following the sixes decision to step
down as senior members of the royal
family it's a huge shift from last
year's Commonwealth day when all eyes
were on Kate and a very pregnant Megan
and their rumoured rift
we actually saw Kate kiss Megan hello
then when they greeted each other there
was a really a really warm energy
between the two of Therma is a bit of a
hard a kiss on each cheek they both
realize that the idea of a feud you know
a royal cat fight between two duchesses
doesn't help any of them and they've
really made an effort to put on a united
front of course Megan and Harry have
been living in Canada with their 9 month
old son Archie
since finalizing Meg's 't proceedings in
January
arrey returned to the UK last week for
several events including an eco-tourism
summit in edinburgh he's made it clear
that we are all just to call him Harry
the 35 year old also met up with rocker
John Bongiovi at London's iconic Abbey
Road Studios the two teamed up with the
Invictus games choir to re-record Bon
Jovi's song unbroken the song will
benefit Harry's beloved games which he
founded for wounded injured and sick
military veterans to compete in sports
based on their abilities Megan will join
her hubby in the UK later this week as
for Archie et have learned that the
nine-month old is expected to remain in
Canada while his parents fulfill their
final royal duties before officially
stepping down on March 31st together the
sixes will attend the endeavour fund
awards and the Mountbatten Music
Festival meanwhile Harry is scheduled to
fly solo at the Silverstone experience
with Lewis Hamilton on March 6 I hope
that men are part of the conversation my
husband certainly is and Megan will
attend International Women's Day events
on March 8th
he caught up with the Duchess's good
friend Janina gavankar at the way back
premier over the weekend where she had
this to say about Megan and her family
returning to North America our entire
friendship has been apart you know it's
like we met 16 years ago and we've just
been apart since so our friendship lives
on FaceTime no matter
we'll take four cute pictures of that
baby please cuz he's adorable
if it's not me somebody well
[Music]